yeah it was terrifying yeah you got a
bunch of frogmen going down navy seals
getting in a van to go do drugs they've
never even heard of before we're all
terrified i was never terrified overseas
right i was never terrified ever in my
life but we were terrified was ourselves
but the medicine's gonna show us
give me the story of how you guys first
met
so we met in context of uh treatment
with psychedelics so i was running a
program
for special operations guys called the
mission within and we had been working
with veterans since 2015
and
uh i had treated some of
michael's or punky's friends
so he was trying to refer
another buddy
and
i don't want to get too much into the
details because it concerns just medical
information but i'll let punky really
dive into how far and how deep he wants
to go
yeah pretty much what martine said it
was uh it was two years ago i had um
four years out of my retirement and uh
was in school and it was
finally the uh the train of life finally
caught up with me and uh
i had reached out to martine to help
another friend of mine to get into a
program that i heard about from a bunch
of other friends but didn't really know
too much about it was a psychedelic
program
uh and it came around at just the right
time for me and just the right time for
my friends as well
uh then i've been involved with uh
martine ever since
what do you mean when you say that the
train of life had come around
yeah for me um you know it's the 30 year
30 years in the seal teams you know in
the normal i say the normal life traumas
that we all have that we kind of run
away from like we're always moving
target
uh until life catches up with us so
uh you know childhood traumas as a kid
um and then life traumas as a young
adult two divorces had a spouse addicted
to opioids living in that kind of
tumultuous world
you know a daughter addicted opioids as
well at the time during the big opioid
epidemic
uh at the same time the war kicked off
so it was like fighting i felt like i
was kind of fighting on two different
fronts
at the same time then a bunch of losses
overseas of friends and then a bunch of
moral injury then a bunch of blast
injuries to my noggin
and
then masking all that with pain pills
and
psychotropics and everything else just
trying to keep the wheels turning and
keep myself moving forward and
eventually
just kind of all caught up with me
were you trying to medicate while you
were still in the teams to keep you
moving forward while you were working
yeah a lot of it was pain management
then a lot of it was just my my
cognitive ability was just severely
declining over time
um i was a breacher in the civil terms
and sniper than just a bunch of blast
injuries from training after combat
um was starting to suffer memory loss
you know massive migraines
uh and then just the frustrations that
come with that you know trying to mask
it and cover it up and kind of move
through life and then on top of all the
other daily things i was struggling with
on the home front and then show up to
work with a smile on my face hey i'm
ready to go right
and like we all do
and um
yeah then i'd gotten out and retired at
the end of uh 2016
uh
went off to grad school was was going to
scope at usc then i had four more of my
friends passed away
uh in the teams and then i had another
close two close friends got blown up in
syria and at that time when that
happened that was just my catalyst for
just meltdown
i agree i do think that most people that
have got problems whatever that's going
on at home or personally or medically
have to put a smile on and go to work
but the risks
of most people's jobs are not quite as
dramatic
as somebody that's doing overwatch as a
sniper or breaching the door so that
everybody else goes in so there is a a
total extra level of of pressure i
suppose to do that
how would you categorize the
atmosphere
generally in the armed forces around
difficulties with
injuries from the past with emotional
traumas from the past at the moment
yes as as far as the injuries go
it's interesting at least in our
community
and i remember when i was going to like
the naval the naval hospital and it was
full of people trying to get out of work
so they're all hanging around the
hospital right
and then in the spec ops community you
don't go to the doctor because you don't
want to lose time at work you want to
work and because if you're absent for
work you may lose that spot right it's
the same as playing on the sports team
right
um so
everyone was always masking pain masking
injuries as long as they could
um
so that just kind of got looked better
now if they needed help they always got
it
uh and then as far as the mental health
aspect of it there was just always this
kind of a fine line but you know we were
always told
hey you know the medical professionals
are here to help you but there's always
just this fear
like hey how much do i share before i
get grounded
or taken offline so you know you answer
the questions and the questions are
always
yes and to a point and then it's no no
no no no and can i get back in the game
right
so the help was always available to us
um
hardly anyone really fully took
advantage of it just i think it
had a fear of just getting sidelined
yeah so you have some uh slightly
contradictory incentives here the guys
don't want to have themselves taken out
of action because it's their job it's
their duty they feel competent at it for
a lot of people it's probably their
sense of meaning in life as well
and you've got i guess this tension
between the two you've got on one hand i
need to look after my health i need to
make sure that i'm not so far gone that
i basically can't do my job anymore but
you're talking about a group of people
that have been trained to be able to put
up with severe levels of discomfort for
extended periods of time i mean that
you've selected for a group of people i
imagine that they're going to be able to
tamp down their emotions and swallow
that discomfort whether it be physical
or emotional for a pretty good period
yeah it was super interesting too you
know because you know i always laugh you
know everyone's like all the steel teams
you know the spec cops like you guys are
always so close we all know [ __ ] about
each other because everyone keeps with
the veil even as close as you are
there's still a degree of separation
uh between the true you and you know and
what you're the face that you're putting
out to your friends
uh so maybe people know kind of maybe
what's going on in your you know your
marital love life your dating life and
stuff like that but as far as the
really deep stuff no one's going to
share the under the underbelly right
they're just not going to expose that
do you think it's possible for somebody
in the seals to develop that kind of a
relationship or do you think that that
would be
uh so antagonistic to the sort of way
that they need to show up
to
the um
atmosphere within the team itself
is it is it possible to be able to be
that open and still be effective as a
member of the team that's maybe seeing
death and destruction every day
yeah i i maybe but i think it would have
to be really brought on so early in the
pipeline right so that's ingrained it's
institutionalized
uh to where that trust factor is really
there
um
you know no one wants to feel that
they're holding anybody back
i think that that's the big thing and
then you know no one wants to be looked
upon as weak
or not being able to handle things you
know if you can't handle your life at
home can you handle life overseas right
and all that kind of goes together so
yeah that's a really good question i'm
not really sure what the answer to that
is yet
i've spoken to a guy called bt urella
who is a buddy of mine for three and a
bit years he started the veteran sports
league
and um he
was
injured tried to save one of his legs
during an ied attack uh and for a very
long time was battling backward and
forward with that couple of suicide
attempts
and um
his the savior that he had out the other
side of that was the fact that he
actually went for amputation now i
didn't realize that if you go for
elective amputation they make you wait i
want to say
six months maybe or a year because they
want to ensure that this is i mean you
can't there's no command and z on this
you can't undo
this particular uh surgery so they need
to make sure that you're well done in
that way but even with him who wasn't in
a he wasn't a seal he was just an
infantryman um
even he was talking about this strange
balance between what you need to show
forward facing the expectation around
you i think the conversation certainly
over the last
15 to 20 years seems to have developed a
lot more than you know go back 100 years
calling it shell shock go back to
vietnam and people coming home and
having very very low levels of support
um
the
really sort of interesting pervasive
thing here is that it's it's not about
the facilities not being there
it's not even
so much anymore about the cultural norms
not being there it's to do with
something that's quite internal to the
individuals themselves and the sense of
expectation and the desire to show up
and perform for the team
i guess
one of the problems there is that's even
more scalable right that's even more
deeply seated you know how are you going
to how are you going to pull that out of
somebody you can offer all of the
treatments and support and and courses
that you want
but how do you actually begin to get
somebody to
to make that decision to reach out for
helps i mean when it comes to you
what
there had to be a day
upon which you woke up and realized
right i i have to make a change here
that i cannot continue to go like this
what what was that point
yeah i mean for me it was what it was
after it was actually after retire
because i remember probably the last
maybe four or five years of my active
duty service i was struggling
um and i was command master chief of a
seal team too you know
and a pretty high level you know listed
leader
uh
running programs and
pretty well respected like all right how
do i maintain this reputation
because your reputation is such a small
unit is so critical right
that's how you get promoted that's how
you get selected
all the other things that kind of go on
with that so uh there's a lot of pride
in it and we all know that pride's the
uh the double edged sword right
um
yeah but it wasn't until after and it
was really when my friend really started
having his breakdown and started
bringing up a lot of stuff in me that my
emotions and memories and everything
just kind of caught up with me
that it was past the point of of my
handling it myself
it's like hey i need some help now i
mean i was suicidal at the time when i
called my team
um and i had been there once before too
so i was like all right this i know what
i know where this is gonna lead very
quickly
but it took me a very long time to get
there
martine what's the beginning of your
story of how you start to
get yourself involved in this world
so that was back uh
1999 i was trying to help a family
member i was in medical school at the
time and she was dealing with a cocaine
addiction
and we had tried all the western
approaches you know what's usually
recommended which is the 12 steps rehab
um you know threats kicking out kicking
her out of the house but nobody nothing
seems to stick with her like nothing was
working
so i had always had an interest in
psychedelics you know starting
as a teenager
and so i knew that there was something
that could potentially help her and i
was aware of ivy game because i didn't
watch the documentary so i looked it up
online and i took her to see a provider
and uh i began it's still pretty obscure
but back then it was even more obscure
there was
not a lot of data there was some
research going on at the island of saint
kitts
and there was one provider that i found
that would you know help her so i took
her and it was really remarkable to see
the pre in the post so she was in denial
that cocaine was a problem because she
had actually started with an eating
disorder and the cocaine you know took
away the hunger so it was a solution and
oftentimes when people fall into
addiction they're self-medicating either
depression or anxiety so the drug serves
a purpose and i think that's often
missed when people look at addiction
they they just view it as a moral
failing or you know a certain weakness
but
it's there's always something underneath
it which is generally trauma so having
you know that experience of me
witnessing her going through this
process and the very next day having
this deep understanding of
her addiction and the need to move away
from it
was was striking because there's nothing
in western medicine
with one single treatment can take you
and give you that perspective
so i
you know stuck in my mind started my
training in my surgery i was going to
become an ophthalmologist
but i
i could never get that out of my head
that there was a treatment that could
help addiction so i took a year off and
started ending in clinic
back in 2000 in mexico city
uh ran that program for a number of
years
until 2015
when i met some veterans that were using
heroin and then they reported their ptsd
was gone
so i was
again intrigued because there's nothing
that we have in our arsenal that
actually cures ptsd we have treatments
to mitigate it to numb symptoms but to
address it at a core level where the
person no longer meets the diagnostic
criteria with a single treatment is
pretty unheard of so i you know started
seeing more veterans and it just
took off after i treated a few seals
they're a very tight-knit community so
they started referring their friends and
um
not just
started growing 2020 2021 was
super busy years and obviously covet had
something to do with it because people
are struggling
and yeah that takes us to now which is
a program that is is just kept growing
over the years
you saw an increase in the number of
veterans suffering with ptsd
during covet
i think it was twofold i think it was uh
the the fact that gyms closed so they
didn't have that outlet of the physical
exercise the social isolation being
stuck at home you know with family is is
very challenging sometimes
um along with greater awareness that
psychedelics are a good option
for addressing what i consider the core
injury into the special operations
community which is mild traumatic brain
injury so it's not even the ptsd i would
say every single operator that has gone
through their training has been exposed
to multiple blast injuries and it
doesn't mean an ied it could be
shooting a mortar being close to rockets
opening doors with explosives even
repetitive gun fire
will cause a certain
um
overpressure wave that can rattle the
brain in a way where it's not designed
to be
you know shooken and this can cause
inflammation this can cause hormone
dysregulation
and
over time sometimes years this this
manifests with anger insomnia depression
anxiety so we look at it as a biological
injury
not so much merely stress or depression
or anxiety there's something going on
physically in the brain of these guys
does that predispose people to
whatever's classified as ptsd now is
that laying some sort of biological
foundation that a psychological
construction can be built on top of
uh definitely and then there's also the
childhood stuff so a lot of the guys
that come through they they come from
uh troubled backgrounds or broken homes
and it's uh pretty common i think that
people gravitate towards the military
because they want more structure
they they want that kind of external
source discipline so
there is the complex ptsd which is
childhood trauma
and post-traumatic stress and then
obviously the brain injury
is
laying kind of this fertile field for
people to then get
further traumatized and display even
more symptoms and then the ways of
coping with it are also problematic
because oftentimes they resort to
alcohol and alcohol is inflammatory so
it makes the brain injury worse so it's
this kind of cycle of of kind of
repeated insults to the brain which
can can lead to
you know pretty pretty bad outcomes um
a lot of the guys that we're training
are suicidal when they come in
um
i suppose one of the particularly
brutal things as well about being an
ex-special forces operative that's
suicidal is you're intimately familiar
with lethal violence too
and uh
it's not good to be able to be
great at killing when the person that
you're looking at potentially harming is
yourself
and
i remember hearing a while ago i think
this is true that women commit suicide
more than men
but women actually try to take their
life more than men it's just that men
are better with lethal force so they're
more successful at taking their life
more successful yeah uh which is i mean
that statistic is
it kind of changed a lot of what i
thought about um how we should be
dealing with and treating suicide i
don't really know what that means
um it means that more women are getting
themselves to the stage where they
consider killing themselves
a very very that's just such an
interesting start so if we were to
if we were to try and create an avatar
of a very
a very common sort of ex-special forces
soldier patient that comes through
the doors of your clinic what would that
person
look like what would their age be what
would they present as what would the
sort of state texture of their mind be
like
what would that what would that avatar
be
so from a demographic standpoint we're
looking at 30 to 40 year olds the
majority of the guys we're treating our
post-9 11 veterans so they've served in
iraq and afghanistan um i think the seal
community has
i don't know if it's self-selected but
it's mostly um
white men um
they're
generally
type a like very um
like they're overachievers they're elite
performers um
in terms of of the issues that they're
dealing with
there's this thing called operator
syndrome that was characterized by a
researcher named chris crew and he he
looked at this complex symptomatology
and presentation that they have and it
includes hormone dysregulation um you
know family issues insomnia
anger
sleep issues we see a lot of sleep apnea
as well
obviously depression anxiety
post-traumatic stress traumatic brain
injury
chronic pain and all these things are
interrelated so when somebody has
chronic pain
it wakes them up at night and then if
you're not sleeping then they're not
sleeping by itself is a type of brain
injury so getting the sleep under
control is one of the most important
things then obviously like the diet that
we have in the west is not helpful and a
lot of the psychopharmaceuticals that
they get prescribed
actually make things worse i mean i've
treated guys that were on 13 different
medications so first we have to get them
off of the medications and that that by
itself is a process because anytime
you're tapering off a medication you're
going to get the opposite effect so if
you've been on xanax for a number of
years when you get off it you'll have
even worse anxiety so it's um it's it's
it's definitely a process and i'm sure
punky cannot do more of the
psychographic of the patients
yeah it's it's been interesting so when
i went through i was i was 50 50
how old am i i was 52. it was a lot of
my peers i mean when i walked in the
room
uh you know we treat six clients a week
and i walk in the room and i know four
of them right through my peers
right and they're like oh you too i get
yeah man me too
but yeah the demographic is just pretty
much everybody in there and just like
martine said you know we're all high
performance it's a high performance
environment um i was on 12 different
medications when i came down
you know psychotropics pain meds
antidepressants anti-anxiety pills
uh just all sorts of this concoctions
like to deal with whatever the hell i
had going on
and interestingly enough i'm off every
single one of those except for my blood
pressure bets
to include my sleep meds i i go to bed
at nine o'clock i wake up at six in the
morning i sleep and i've got sleep happy
and i went years and years with zero
sleep
um but yeah the demographic it's it's 30
to 50 and typically because it's
the guys you know we typically they're
post-service veterans
that are coming in so they've already
either retired or they separated early
so you know you're looking at you know
probably 60 percent of guys that are 20
to 30-year veterans and then the rest
uh that separated early
so it's a big swath
can you explain the experience of going
through the doors of that treatment
center for the first time punky yeah it
was terrifying um
it's funny
yeah you got a bunch of frog men going
down navy seals you know getting in a
van to go do drugs they've never even
heard of before we're all terrified or
like
i was never terrified overseas right i
was never terrified ever in my life
uh um but we were terrified was
ourselves right what the medicine is
going to show us so
uh no i had reached out to my team for a
friend of mine and got in touch with him
and then he hooked me up uh for medical
screenings i got screened medically um
then i got aligned with the coach for my
preparation training
which is key to all of this what does
that what does that look like your cycle
dark experience what's the uh
preparation training look like
yeah so i had zero experience with any
you know
recreational pharmacology or
psychedelics at all in high school and
college
so what the coach really walked me
through michael cynthia was just like
hey here's one here's what the medicines
can do here's what they can't unlock
here's how you navigate the space when
you're in it
um
here's how to build your
frame your intentions fight your
expectations so you don't set yourself
up for failure going into medicine
um here's how you navigate the medicine
when you're in it and then hey
here's what's going to come up
afterwards or here's what can come up
afterwards and here's how we work
through this
um that was key
um
and then i got screened medically went
down i got my my heart checked out
did some labs and stuff make sure i was
and then i had to taper off all those
crazy meds that i was already on
uh and then went down
no we had
the way we run the retreat in the same
same as when i went through we had six
clients per weekend
uh so we went down met up with our
therapists and our coaches there's a
therapist down there trauma therapist
uh there's veteran coaches that are down
there typically from the spec ops
community so their peers
you know helping the guys through
uh then there's a cook down there that's
also working in the space forever
uh then there's the organic medical
staff for the clinic so
so we got down to the house uh we did a
bunch of preparation work when we got
there again kind of everyone sharing
their story hey who's who in the zoo
here how did we get here
and it was interesting because we're
going around the circle of telling
stories and here's here's guys that i
know and that knew me and this is the
first of any of us i've ever heard the
other guy's story like oh
wow i didn't know that about you i'm
like i'm sorry i didn't know that about
you
um
yeah then
later that night we got uh
ekgs done and some more lab work done
and then we did a little fire ceremony
we kind of walked through our intentions
we burned
and we wrote down our intentions for us
to receive from the medicine and then we
wanted to get out of our lives which for
me was
i thought the story is almost the same
right shame anger guilt pain anguish
all that stuff hate
um
and then we burned that in a small fire
ceremony and then we took the medicine
uh the medicine we took is abigail from
the above root in this case it's in pill
form it's an isolate
uh so we took that and then went
upstairs and laid there it seemed like
for two days because it's only like an
hour
waiting for the medicine to kick in
and uh talk to me about it
you're someone that hasn't played around
with psychedelics beforehand
you are at a particular point in your
life where things have got
pretty intense you've needed to reach
out for help you've had this built up
now obviously the preparation and the
counseling will have tried to calm you
down but you're not going to be able to
get away from the fact that i've just
taken something it's inside of me
there's no going back
what's that one hour
before everything kicks in what does
that feel like
i think the hour was shorter than the
fact of the time that i had the pill in
my hand staring at it right
like
am i going to take this one that's just
a red pill with a blue pill right
you know and then i was just like [ __ ]
it what have i got to lose you know
three two weeks ago i had a gun to my
head so screw this so i took the pill
and then just lay there waiting and
obviously the anticipation and they even
the weeks going into it you know stuff
starts to come up the medicine works
before you're ever even in the medicine
and just starts unearthing things so it
was really kind of beautiful um
my medicine journey played out very
interesting uh league for me so in the
seal teams i did a lot of targeting um
and just
hunting people down we used a program in
the in the still things called the
palantir it's a link diagram
program it's all i cause and effect and
stuff so to get to x i need to go here
but i need to find this person first and
this person this person
it actually did that with me all the way
through my life so it would bring up
people and flash them in front of my
face it was like
oh that's my mother that's my father
that's this person but it would keep
going until i recognized them at a
certain age
and then it took me back into their life
and it played out their life and then it
brought it back to our intersect
and then played that forward so i got to
see you know kind of where my abuses
happen as a kid but also how it played
out for my parents and other stuff and
then other people that came into my
lives um same thing for overseas i had a
bunch of situations that happened it
just kind of kept playing it for me it's
like
plays for you a million different ways
it's all going to turn out the same um
so by the end of that journey
i kind of came out i was just like
which is complete understanding and
reconciliation
so i got to basically relive my entire
life over again without the emotion
attached to it um
and it was powerful i remember i just
woke up and i cried i was
like i had a million people to apologize
to a million people to forgive and
uh the fact that i wanted to forgive
people was huge because that was a huge
anchor right
um
and then
you know i came out of the medicine
fairly early in the morning other guys
came out a little bit later in the day
uh how long is the duration of the trip
it's a good yeah
about 10 to 12 hours in it
and then you're out typically by
roughly noon the next day
so there's a really peak there's a peak
period of time where you're really deep
in the medicine that slowly starts to
weigh off
uh it is a stimulant
so you're not really sleeping because
your brain is just remapping itself and
it's working all night
and when i came out too like my i felt
like someone put a vacuum cleaner to my
brain like it was still it was finally
quiet and i've always had monkey mind
and chatter and all that noise that's
always in there
and it was just completely quiet which
was
very eerie and scary at the same time
and peaceful at the same time it was
nice to have
um
and then the other guys kind of came out
a little bit later in the day
um some people had rough ugly journeys
mine was rough but it wasn't
painful for me to see was just very
teaching
some people had very joyous journeys
some people had very
lost in space journey so everyone's
journey is extremely different it's
interesting too
same medicines you know and actually
some of the same traumas going into it
but the journeys play out entirely
differently for everybody
um
and then that night we did some more
integration work
pretty smoke that day avogan's really
taxing on the body
uh it's extremely draining
uh
and then we did prep work for sunday uh
for sunday morning we did 5mu tmt which
is from the store in the desert toad
some people call the god molecule the
spirit molecule
uh super powerful medicine always laugh
like who figured these things out right
a bunch of kids going in the desert they
found a toad they cooked it over fire
and they talked to god
i mean how does this thing play out
yeah but it's a beautiful beautiful
medicine and if you look back into
history too the the toad and the
mushrooms like in all these artifacts
all over the world
so that medicine the way i like to
explain it is you know where the abigain
really dove in to a lot of cerebral
memory and just unearth stuff
the five is a very powerful emotional
medicine
and it goes in and just unearths all
these
i like to just say suppressed emotions
and you're talking a lifetime of
suppressed emotions
um
happiness pain sadness guilt anger shame
all that stuff has a voice to it
and it causes damage um
and if you let it then it'll get there
and it comes out and
uh to someone outside the room it can
sound like there's helter skelter going
in there and
murder death kill or chucky cheese
birthday party or complete joy or the
super bowl depending upon what's going
on
uh
to the guy or girl that's there we're
just laying there just expelling all
this energy and this emotion that needs
to come out and on the other side of
that
is ego disillusion just complete
connectivity right back to yourself
again
i fought my medicine it was too much
love for me like i just received this
flood dose of love and i didn't want it
i couldn't handle it i fought it
and then i tried to get back into it i
couldn't get back in
and then i thought i failed because i
couldn't do it
and uh but i remember i was talking to
my coach cynthia at the time
she was like no you felt it you saw it
yeah i did so just go well you can get
there again
so
after i left after that weekend for me
it's like all right i know what's on the
other side of this curtain
um and i'm just going to continue to do
my work and get there so it's about
three four months later that i finally
broke all the way through with a with a
different medicine
um with the intent of just
allowing myself to surrender
give it in but i had already the heavy
lifting i had already done the big
boulder had already been moved
right from
out of the way when i was down in mexico
um
other guys and girls the other guys with
me had just these beautiful spiritual
journeys
um and then some again were dark you
know everyone's journey is just
completely unique some people have
beautiful abigail journeys and and
horrible five meow journeys and
sometimes it's flipped over you know the
other way around
but eventually in the weeks after it
just kind of all starts to play out you
start to get these downloads and
everything just kind of falls right back
in line so it all doesn't happen right
in the medicine that's what happens
after that
um and if i had not had my coach cynthia
you know work with me at the time
i could have easily just kind of gone in
the self-destructive mode of like hey i
[ __ ] this up i failed this i didn't do
it right
i wasted these people's time and all
that and it wasn't the case at all
so that was a huge win for me
yeah just a beautiful a beautiful
medicine pairing and just the container
that the mission within it set down that
was just so powerful like
yeah got a bunch of guys to come in
there were a bunch of alpha males but
were entirely just extremely scared at
the time
um
but they set the right container just it
was
it just helped us navigate through that
space
what was the medication that you used
the
after four months what was the different
thing that you used that time
after that i uh
going out to a reservation out here in
san diego and i've done a uh very heavy
psilocybin dose with the indians out
here
um
but have you sold simon does do you know
how much did you know how much it was
and got and gotten through there
uh 20 grams
sorry
[Laughter]
20 20 euros
okay
martin can you try and explain
what's going on
in the brain
that's causing this particular
restructuring why that combination of
iboga and 5meo
and and how is it that
this there's obviously something
functional that happens or something
physical that happens but then there's
also something psychological something
emotional maybe even something spiritual
how does all of this work together
yeah no you did it right on the nail on
the head which is it's that there's a
physiologic physiological changes
there is psychological changes and
there's also a spiritual effect of these
compounds
from a physiological standpoint either
gain is is it's not considered a clean
drug in that it doesn't affect one
single receptor so ionian infects about
50 different neuroreceptors so it's
working on many levels on you know the
dopaminergic system on serotonin on the
opioid receptors
um
it's
increasing communication between both
hemispheres
it's
helping stimulate neurogenesis so it it
it elevates levels of bdnf and gdnf
which is brain derived neurotropic
factor and glial derived from a tropic
factor so there's there's new brain
cells being grown
um
and then from a psychological standpoint
the iv gain is a shadow work so it
allows a person to deal with unprocessed
trauma like unfinished business
uh things that they've been avoiding
childhood stuff that they might have
repressed
a lot of the trauma that we have is
pre-verbal so it happens before the age
of five
and because the language centers in the
brain are not developed it doesn't get
encoded in language so there's no way to
access access it just through
psychotherapy because you're trying to
use a semantic framing to to
access things that are like visionary
almost like they're just um energetic
patterns are encoded so with the
navigating journey because you're
gaining this perspective and seeing
yourself as a child and you're floating
in the room something like this observer
standpoint from buddhism where you're
just
objectively observing without the
emotional pain of the memory so you
don't get traumatized but you're now an
adult so you're seeing it through the
eyes of an adult and you're able to then
recontextualize what happened to that
child and understand it better from a
different perspective so many times you
know we blame our parents
for things they did or they didn't do
but we don't realize like what they were
dealing with at the time or the trauma
that they had so being able to see it in
that kind of broader swath of
like their history as well leads to a
lot of forgiveness and understanding
um
but it's not easy because you're you're
confronted with opportunities you've
missed people you've hurt
um and just you know ways that we've
shown up in relationship with other
people that we're not
kind of in our
in alignment with our highest self
sometimes you're even shown how you
were perceived by that person through
their own eyes it's almost like you're
in the back of their head seeing
yourself
like how you how you reacted to things
they did
um so a lot of people you know they want
to go home and fix relationships right
away but we tell them to like just take
some time
because it
the person might not be able to the
person you hurt might not be able to
receive that information so a lot of
shadow work with the ib gain and then
the five mio is uh very different
because it's it's more of the mystical
experience so it's that sense of oneness
of unity of connection people report
being in the presence of god feeling
that they've gone to heaven almost then
recognizing themselves as divine beings
so
going from you know the shadow work and
and kind of these difficult experiences
to then uh the 5meo is is a very healing
process because some of the stuff that
the ibogaine shows you is just hard to
integrate
because it might not even be your stuff
it could be just the pain of the planet
you know factory farms or war or things
that are happening
that are
that we might not be aware of but it
shows you that and then the five and
meow just blows it all away it shows you
that everything is as it should be and
you know that everything is perfect then
in in in your control from a
physiological standpoint to 5meo
reduces inflammation and when you have a
brain injury that is related to blast
exposure when you have a mild traumatic
brain injury
and you are able to reduce inflammation
the brain can heal itself so the
neurogenesis from the iv gain and the
reduced inflammation from the 5ml go
perfectly hand in hand so there's a
synergistic effect you're also working
on different neurotransmitter systems
um
and like punky was saying the the
experience itself might be 30 of the
healing
but the integration of the experience is
70 it's what you do with it it's the
meditation the yoga
the ice baths um you know regular
coaching sessions you know relying on on
your therapist and really taking
advantage of the resources that
that are available and this is a
lifelong process it's not you know one
month three months it's it's for the
rest of your life you really have to
work on yourself to maintain these
benefits um if you don't then the
experience can fade after two or three
months
funky did you do
your ibogaine
your five meow
and then your psilocybin and was that
pharmacologically was that the
lion's share of the work that needed to
be done
no
you know i like to say it's peeling the
onion right i didn't get here in one day
and i'm not going to get out of this in
one day either
but what i got
from that one weekend in mexico was
enough to really move the needle in a
significant way
um i got the it allowed me to get to the
x which therapy was never getting me to
um but even though i got to the ex
there's still more stuff that kept
coming up i was like whoa there's more
there's more there's more
so you know subsequent uh medicine
journeys for me been able to help me
deal work through that
uh
so typically i do all my work and then
if i get to a sticking point that i
can't get any further
uh with all the right things i'm doing
and with my coaching with my therapist
and sometimes i lean into medicine
sometimes it shows me more
you know i get more more downloads or i
get more insight
sometimes there's nothing to see
sometimes i just need to offload some
some energy or just some built up you
know stuff that just needs to go away
but i don't i don't do much medicine i
haven't touched uh psychedelics it's
always been a year now
um so that first year was pretty heavy
for me and just kind of
peeling back that onion as fast as i
could
um and then two
they all they kind of kept falling in
front of me like right at the right time
like i would just bump into someone that
knew somebody and i would go
uh experience another uh another
modality
uh because all these medicines have just
such a different energy to them
uh but it was the right medicine for me
at the right time
and uh
yeah they're just entirely different
um
i i think
i had zero practice going in when i when
i met martin i couldn't meditate i had
zero mindfulness practice i had
i had no
any good practice whatsoever other than
throwing weights around that was it
so
uh my self-care and my
self-understanding was to appoint is
almost zero
well it's entirely different now you
know just the way that i moved through
life
what is the reason
for
working with
martin do you work with anything else
other than ibogaine and five emmy or is
that are those the two that you work
with mostly
so
uh we've been working mostly with
ibogaine and fibermeo and we've done a
few retweets with psilocybins so with
mushrooms
and these have mainly been for the
spouses of veterans
uh that have also experienced trauma
just by you know being in that community
and also living living with them and
going through the process of grieving
and loss because they've got so much
death
um so yeah we we have retreats for soul
side and for a game
what's the reason for not using
uh peyote or for not using uh non-five
meow
yeah so the um there's uh obviously
benefits to say a peyote journey or an
ayahuasca journey i think with with
ayahuasca
you you have to be trained in that
lineage and i don't feel qualified to
administer that we our partner with a
nonprofit called heroic hearts project
that runs ayahuasca retreats so we
generally just refer people to them if
they want to do work with
with i with ayahuasca the peyote is a
little bit challenging because of
sustainability issues so it's hard to to
promote
um a compound which is sacred to native
americans and which is running out
because it takes so many years to mature
so mostly when people want to try
mescaline i would direct them to san
pedro which has very similar effects in
this which a lot more common what about
ketamine what about mdma i've seen a lot
of talk about that as treatment for ptsd
as well
yeah ketamine is wonderful as a kind of
a short term
staunch the bleeding type of
intervention when somebody's suicidal we
can refer them to academy provider in
the us because it's the one psychedelic
that's already legal so you can find it
everywhere in the us from the ama it's a
bit problematic because it's not legal
in mexico so ibogaine and meow are legal
they were never
scheduled so they're
uh basically not recognized by mexican
law as being compounds of abuse
um
but with psilocybin it falls into more
of a gray area where it can be used
ceremoniously if used by indigenous
people in indigenous contexts
um other countries like jamaica they're
they're very open about psilocybin so we
are uh setting up a retreat center there
which is going to be mainly for military
families so
spouses and adult children but also for
female veterans that are dealing with
sexual trauma
uh which we have to separate the men
from the women because
oftentimes the perpetrators were other
uh people in the military so
what is the
current legality around this in america
at the moment if you're somebody that's
been in the u.s special forces
you you simply can't get this legally in
america i'm guessing
uh only ketamine can be can be done
legally uh what what punky was referring
to of native american reservations there
is a dispensation there that is that
there's tribal sovereignty so there's a
native american church there's also some
ayahuasca
um
churches that have received exemptions
but mostly the work has to happen under
kind of fda approved uh trials
and there there are a few
there's something called expanded access
where they're
already uh they've proven to the fda
that these compounds are effective
specifically mdma and sell simon so now
that there's a possibility to
start offering it more widely but it's
still very limited and small most sites
only get five slots
so
it's it's difficult um so most people
are traveling they're going to different
locales overseas where
these things are legal
what is the potential usefulness of this
for people who
don't have super strong ptsd it sounds
like
a lot of people may have had trauma that
has been ingrained
before they can even remember it
certainly before they can semantically
put it into words
so
is there a case to be made that far more
people than just veterans perhaps might
need this
um i would say they don't need it but if
they they would definitely most people
have trauma that they haven't processed
there's
just things that they they might not be
aware of
uh there is some evidence that
micro dosing can help with creativity
and just
be a better option for people than
adderall
so it it does have some elements of
increasing human performance
and
making people more empathetic more
connected to themselves
more aware better in relationships
um
just nicer humans
it makes me think
how many people at the moment we've got
a
pandemic of anxiety of people being
very very concerned about their mental
health at the moment and you can lay
this at the feet of social media if you
want but there's a lot of other things i
think that are contributing to this
increases in single-parent households uh
higher levels of uncertainty about life
paths for the future lack of connection
to religion lack of connection to your
local community you know the list is is
pretty endless of the grand narratives
that have collapsed so that people now
feel a little bit atomized um
i'm just wondering how much of that
you know how how much
a therapeutic session of something like
ibogaine could perhaps
help them
yeah probably i mean i would recommend
like if somebody's going to try check it
alex i would actually start with breath
work or with floatation therapy and then
move on to psychedelics and then of the
psychedelics ivy gain is is you know
like the big gun is that mount everest
of experiences so there's some
psychological
challenges that it can bring up but also
there's some physical risks it can it
can affect your heart rate it can cause
arrhythmias in combination with other
drugs so it's definitely delicate
um
ayahuasca on five meal can be hard to
integrate so when people ask me like
where they should start once they want
to do a psychedelic journey ketamine is
probably the easiest entry point
um because it's short
you know can be manageable you can
titrate the dose really carefully
and then mushrooms would be the next one
so i do think that for the wider
population that is dealing with this
kind of this
sense of disconnection and and
there's a lot of you know causes to it i
think we're disconnected from each other
we're disconnected from nature very few
people find meaning in their jobs
uh so having community uh especially if
it's like guided through a trained
facilitator and there is a psychedelic
type practice could be transformative
for us as a society
well in an ideal world we would be able
to
fix the cause of the problem rather than
finding a solution to it on the other
side right at the moment we are
retrospectively going back and then
trying to okay something went wrong
let's let's go and fix it it'll be much
better for nothing to have gone wrong in
the first place
you mentioned there about the fact that
uh ibogaine particularly can be quite
challenging
are there any
um
issues of dissociation of psychosis of
people having onsets of schizophrenia or
any issues like that that come about due
to people taking the medicine
we haven't run into that but we screen
people carefully there's definitely
people that shouldn't take psychedelics
so when somebody is manic it can make
them more manic so that's one
contraindication
if people are not in touch with reality
if they're schizophrenic if they're
hearing voices it's also not a good
time to be taking psychedelics
as well as some drugs that are
contrary indicated
so
we haven't had issues with ibogaine uh
i've seen some people that have trouble
integrating 5ml when used on its own and
that's why it's so important to have
a coach or a therapist that is well
versed in the medicine that is checking
in with you afterwards because sometimes
it's as simple as getting grounded like
eating food taking a warm shower or
getting a massage but when you're not
aware of this and you're having these
like reactivations these flashbacks of
the five meow journey people like they
don't sleep they don't eat and then that
by itself makes them spin out so it it
it's definitely uh something that's
that's happening in the community i've
also seen it with ayahuasca where people
come back and they're just not the same
for months afterwards
what's next for you then punky in terms
of your personal
journey of
recovery of moving forward
i mean how
just how much have you managed to undo
with the
therapeutic and
medicinal solutions that you've looked
at
that's a good question you know so i i
probably took a year of really just
diving in and
i just kept moving the needle right and
um
you know i finally i remember i hit one
medicine journey where there was no more
trauma it was just done
it was just me finally meeting my young
self and i got to walk my young self
back through
you know the happy stages of my life the
dark stages
uh and that was an interesting journey
and i would just woke up i was like okay
we're done we're moving forward now
uh but it's really it's like
it's controlling the things that you can
control right and focusing on those
things that you can control so
can i control my sleep yeah can i
control my thought patterns yes
can i control what goes into my mind and
what goes into my ears and what goes
into my uh
my mouth yeah i can so i'm focused on
that and just being very mindful
um
stuff comes up still but now i'm ahead
of it like i recognize it and
i just i'm able to sit with it now vice
reacting to it
and then i can just really kind of dive
into it so it's been an interesting
journey on this side of the equation
vice where i was before
um and now i have this huge community of
guys and girls that are on the side i
like to say on this side of the medicine
that i can talk to you know
that are my peers you know my wife my
friends you know my coach i'm a coach
now as well
um and it's just been
my relationships are entirely different
uh they're very more much more intimate
and more open and authentic with all my
friends
so there's no more veil like this is
what you get this is me there's no
there's no hiding anything
so i don't have
i'm not i'm i don't feel i'm ever at
risk to ever go down that path again
um
will i
you know dive into the medicines more
if something comes up i feel i need to
or i'm curious about it yeah but i don't
lean on another question for me it's not
something i chase i'm not a uh i'm not a
psychonaut
um for me it was it was healing it
wasn't about expanding consciousness
um so i got that part out of the way and
i'm just trying to live my best life
right now while i can and just give back
to others
what is
if there's some people that are in the
special forces or perhaps
are looking to come out pretty soon and
are thinking
that sounds an awful lot like the
situation that i am in the situation
that you were in is now what they're
feeling
what would you want to say to them
reach out yeah that's the funny thing um
every client we have down there and
myself included were never self-referred
someone else brought them they referred
them right so someone else threw a life
ring out for that person so
we're not self-arresting no we're not
asking for help
and that's not a pride it's out of fear
it's out of shame it's out of all sorts
of things
so really it's just knowing that you
have a community of brothers and sisters
that will help you if you reach out
it's the same in any aspect of life if
you ask for help somebody will help you
uh you just have to ask um
and we've got a beautiful community
that's been in this space for a long
time uh you know it was underground for
a long time everyone's slowly coming to
the surface now because we're not
helping anybody by staying underground
we're just not doing it
um and the momentum is already moving
forward so
i think the narrative's changing so it's
safe to be in this space now you know
and maybe in some work environments it
may not be
but it's getting more and more
accepted
um
and
it's safer than what we've been doing
which is taking this these this
pharmacology
you know
this
these medicines that we're taking they
were actually compounding the issues
that we already had
um
but the big ones just
ask for help reach out um
come to us come to someone we're not
ever telling anybody to come to us we're
not the only retreat out there
um
we're one of the few that specializes in
treating veterans
and we're run by veterans
uh but just yeah ask for help
what was your process of starting to
become a facilitator or uh an assistant
with the organization
yeah marchito reached out and he goes
hey we've got a big group coming down
here um you want to help out you want to
go yeah i'll drive the truck you know
i'll wash the dishes i'll clean the
towels and
walk guys to the bathroom and it started
just like that just holding space for
guys and then
i think when you and i started this
conversation i said yeah i walked in the
room and there's six guys i know four of
them
it was just more and more and more of
that i was like damn i know all these
guys
and so that
really kind of shifted you know my
missions like hey these are my people
and wanting to go down um
initially i i think i probably jumped in
too soon trying to help i hadn't done a
lot of my own work and
you know you go from a non-feeling
non-caring guy to being completely
busted wide open and being an empath
and taking on everything is like i need
to back out of the space real bad
and uh but no it was really healing
because then i got to really learn
um
you know what i think we kind of go
through life thinking our trauma is so
unique to us that no one's gonna
understand it
and then you hear all these guys and
girls story and if there's two of them
that are exactly the same
if not three and trauma's trauma right
no matter when it happens or how it
happens still trauma it's something that
got you in
allowed you to get in your own way and
it stopped you from moving you know your
full potential
uh so got into that and then
got serious about it so i took a
psychedelic integration coaching course
really dove into that started coaching
after the sessions and now i go down i'm
a facilitator i'm a coach i manage the
operations down there
and uh it was i just love the work
where can people go if they want to find
out more about what it is that you guys
do and and the process of everything
yes so our website is missionwithin.org
um and then we're also funded by
non-profits so the seal future fund
refute seal futurefoundation.org
heroichartsproject.org
and
thehopeproject.org
or they fund we're probably 60 i think
60 if not 70 donor funded for the
clients that could come down
and then the rest are self-paced
is this available for anybody worldwide
or are you only taking people from the
us now we take everybody we're very
pretty heavy on veterans
uh but national analogy doesn't doesn't
really matter
martine anything to add before we finish
up for
today uh we're recruiting for a study
that we have uh going on so this is a
gold star study
this is women that lost men in combat or
to mental health issues
so information is on the website and
they would be
coming to ut at austin getting their
brain scanned and then going to retreat
coming back for the us getting another
brain scan so we want to see
what the effects of psilocybin are on
prolonged brief
uh as well as five meo and these would
be separate groups so
um yeah i just want to get the word out
on that study because i think it's
important to
also help the widows of
men who have served what's the website
again for that
missionwithin.org
gentlemen i
very much appreciate the stuff that
you're doing i think that it's
uh long overdue to try and give people
that have served their country and put
their bodies and their minds on the line
to keep everybody else safe and and free
uh the fact that you you go through all
of the sacrifices and then potentially
come home to
suffer more it feels particularly unfair
so i i really really applaud the work
that you're doing it's incredibly
inspiring and long may continue what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace